on va parler de l'amour est dans le pré
puisque ça y est c'est terminé l'amour
est dans le pré est finie cette saison
c'est une saison une bonne saison où
c'est une saison en demi teinte
c'est une bonne saison merci terminera
vraiment la semaine prochaine exactement
c'est vrai que c'est alors le top 5 des
audiences voilà je vous le dis de la
veille alors on peut voir voilà que
l'amour est dans le pré était encore 4
millions et 18% des marchés merci mais
heureusement que vous êtes là vous parce
que pas voir les audiences d'hier s'il
vous plaît merci si on peut se réveiller
en régie merci ça arrive qu'on plus tôt
cette année merci ça ils vont voilà ça
arrive mais on s'en fout ça a bien
marché car gay on vous a fait le top 5
des moments préférés nos moments
préférés de cette troisième saison en
cinquième position c'était autour d'une
assiette de produits de la mer que la
conversation des risques peu à peu
daniel demande à l'une de ses
prétendantes si elle aime les fruits de
mer et bien entendu sa part en cacahuète
regardez merci non on s'en fout tu vas
monter une femme de poissons l'on t'aime
l'arrêt
on n'a pas la tienne en tout cas je
t'aime l'arrêt pas la sienne en tout cas
moi j'adore j'adhère voilà c'est
magnifique
alors non mais c'est assez drôle ça
arrange oui moi je trouvais que c'était
une saison très décevante
voilà il désolé isabelle voilà parce que
je trouve que l'on aimait beaucoup de
méchancetés beaucoup d'aigreur beaucoup
de goujaterie
je trouve que les les agriculteurs
avaient toutes là là là les bonnes
intentions qui l'ont ils font pas assez
d'efforts pour bien accueillir leurs
candidates et les candidats de cette
année est mal castet assez transparente
il n'y a pas eu de choses moches mais je
préfère sa sauce scénarisé et qu on
s'amuserait pas là on s'emmerdait
sérieusement chaque fait et c'était la
saison la plus chiante bizarrement je ne
suis pas d'accord vous dit tout et son
contraire ils jouissaient pas possible
lorsque c'est scénarisé vous dites ça
devient une émission de télé réalité il
ya plus de véracité
ils sont tous des comédiens ils font
tout ça pour passer à la télé et quand
justement et ben justement ils sont pas
castet parce qu'ils sont des archétypes
mais justement parce qu'ils ont vraiment
envie de trouver l'amour vous dites oh
c'est chiant alors moi je trouve qu'il
ya eu des bons moments pareils en
quatrième position c'est toujours à
table que la conversation dérape et
cette fois c'est sûr le lâcher prise
vous nous direz ce que vous en pensez
benjamin castaldi tu peux tout lâché en
fait tu vois tu es dans ton et personne
te vois tu peux tout faire tout lâcher
[Rires]
je vois la première nuit lâche
est-à-dire en troisième position c'est
le moment gênant ou la famille de
christopher montre à sa dulcinée une
photo de lui très jeune avec un bouton
sur le visage regarder et là il avait un
petit bouton save été pris par une
photographe et à boutons un bouton sur
le bout du grand merci à chaque bout du
gland verdâtre du nom si cette bague ou
faire baisser ces voix là c'est marrant
moi j'aime bien non c'est nous a déjà
entendu les abeilles là-dessus bolide ou
moi j'essaie mais mary scherpe pas sur
le gland mais sur le rêve d'entendre sur
le gland non non non parce que moi j'ai
jamais aimé cette émission et je sens
que je ne suis pas déçu parce qu'en fait
je m'attendais à rien et je trouve que
c'est toujours très gênant d'être dans
la salle de bains dans la chambre à
coucher dans la salle à manger
alors on les regarde on est un peu
touché rions se marre un peu on se moque
un peu de à chaque fois qu'on a reçu ici
des agriculteurs de l'amour est dans le
pré le public est mort de rire des
convois des vidéos on se moque de band
en se marrant mais donc gentil alors en
deuxième position un autre moment gênant
c'est lorsque christophe et aurélia
parle de pilosité
voilà c'est tout ce que donc on se moque
calmez-vous bordeaux
non je
j'ai toujours une barber de 4 5 jours
toi tu trace alors je m'épile vraiment
excitant je m'épile je ne me rase pas
bien
[Musique]
c'est rien c'est marrant moi je les
filles et enfants première position de
cette saison c'est patrice vous allez
voir ses meetings il est dans un dancing
et ils disent dans un dancing ce n'est
avec ses deux prétendantes et lâche un
dos un peu gênant concernant ses soucis
intestinaux regarder que ça risque
d'être long je sais pas
as-tu constitué de pluie
mais c'est normal le même nom mais c'est
normal je vais essayer
vous inquiétez pas si je suis limite je
voyais tuner non plus voilà
l'amour est dans le pré donc voilà le
bilan il est il est plutôt bon ok ce
milieu c'est mort
il s'étendra souple et on en reparlera
la semaine prochaine merci les chiffres
avec bien sûr sur la dernière